good
morning
welcome back to the morning toast happy
hump day oh my god it's wednesday
happy wednesday happy hump day
to everyone who celebrates and hey jax
how you doing i'm doing great happy hump
day it's a special hump day because
bruno you can't see him which is so
unfortunate for you disgusting he got
groomed this morning he said theo's
getting groomed today gorgeous with his
fresh crop he's so handsome for his
mommy and he wanted to come on the show
to show everyone his new look so
everyone this is bruno's fresh chop he
has a fresher haircut than his mommy
and he's so excited to be here you know
what must be nice about being a dog
like you get a haircut and since they
don't really have like emotional
intelligence like there's no breakdown
that ensues afterwards you know like no
pulling your hair out in the bathroom no
freaking out that your hair is too short
like it's just a haircut that must be
like what it's like to be a boy
or
they're freaking out on the inside have
no way to communicate that he doesn't
like this haircut that i give him every
few weeks and that he wants his long
mane like samson
potentially but i think my
idea of what it's like is better i think
bruno loves having short hair even
though this isn't the typical cavalier
crop cavaliers are meant to be very long
and you know grow dogs grow now very
long hair but bruno loves to play and
you can't play hard with with long hair
like that so i think he loves his buzz
cut
bruno loves to play hard he plays hard
he works hard and he plays hard hate
that the truth don't we all
um it's wednesday we have a fabulous
show for everyone we've got to your
toasters which is
a highlight of my week um they're quite
unique today i wonder how we're gonna
get these girlies out of these pickles
well i know if anyone can it's us
hundred percent who will solve any crime
by dinner time who you gonna call dear
toasters
um
so before we dive in little shameless
self promo uh growth no job.com tour i
have a show tomorrow in red bank new
jersey very limited seats left i suggest
you come um and then i'm headed to the
pnw pacific northwest portland and
seattle um in september so
girlwithnojob.com tour if you like what
you see here come see me on tour i'm
gonna do stand up we're gonna have a
good time we're gonna drink spritz
you're gonna hang out with like-minded
individuals which is really one of the
better parts of the not like other girls
tour is being around like-minded
individuals definitely so when are those
pnw shows just so i know when you'll be
leaving town i i know because it's my
wedding anniversary i have to do better
about like booking shows around you know
personal times this tour was ben's
birthday
and our anniversary so he's not too
happy with me but like i have to work on
my art you know 100 okay so that's
september 17th and 18th
okay cool yeah no that's like right when
i was planning on coming to new york so
i'm glad i know that i'm glad you shared
that information with me oh lordy lord
it's okay i haven't booked my i can
pivot
pivot
like sometimes this show would be so
much better if you watched friends no i
think the show would be worse i think
it's so important that we represent both
camps of friends files
and friends loathers
you are that of the latter friends
loaders and your friends file
yeah i guess that's true like it's
important to have dynamic discussions
here in the morning toes which is
exactly what we do
i just wish you know
i wish you could understand like my
references you know
i do understand a lot of them because
you explain them to us
just like not as fun when you have to
explain
okay well i'm glad that we're we really
don't do that anymore you've kind of
moved on from friends i feel like you
don't not that you've moved on you're
just you know in a different place i
feel like the way that you used to watch
friends now you read
books for comfort a hundred percent and
um i just with friends for me i like go
in waves there'll be like a period of
weeks where i'll just rewatch it and so
it's very topical and you know top of
mind but then you know there are weeks
and months that go by that i don't watch
it when i'm on tour i watch it if the
hotel has like uh
chromecast i love a good chromecast
great i couldn't be more proud that
through my work and my endeavors you
have replaced watching friends with
reading books my work here is done a
hundred percent like what are you doing
you're washing your hands of me
you know i can set you free and let you
fly and you can work on someone else who
should i work on next
there's only so many people who will
allow me into their personal space to
work on them
the thing is you should work on ben
ooh getting him to read actually you
know i've been working when i read you
know who i've been working on though
olivia it's going nowhere oh okay
when you try and get to turn someone
into a reader the first step is like
deconstructing what they know about
reading because what we all know about
reading is like torture fest 2000 from
high school like having a pit in your
stomach when the summer's almost over
because you haven't started the curious
incident of the dog in the middle of the
night like the sheer anxiety and panic
that would come from books when we were
kids has stuck with us all well into
adulthood it's not even that actually
that i confront with some um reticent
readers it's that they think they know
what reading is about they're like no i
know i read sometimes i and i don't want
a kindle i like the feeling of a book
and when there's a book i want to read i
read it and i read on vacation
but it's like
you're closing yourself off to a world
of opportunity they think that reading
means you know
no tv no fun it's just rigorous
scholastic work and it's all the tv all
the fun plus your imagination and your
brain is doing some leg work
anyways it's that it's like olivia being
like no i know about reading i just
don't want to do it
but you don't know about reading yeah
and i also think that people really
underestimate like how much time they
have um like i i think when people think
of their free time like they want to
watch tv and scroll on their phone and
like be with their families and you can
fit reading into that like you
definitely can
look at claudia who scrolls on their
phone watches tick tock and beats with
their family more and don't get me wrong
my screen time on tick tock has
definitely gone down but it's still
above average it's taken a hit it's
taking a hit but i don't think that's
necessarily a bad thing for me
not at all whatsoever so i'll work on
olivia and ben two extremely stubborn
people very sad in their ways
but you know who's more stubborn me
yeah it's true like you're not stubborn
you're persistent persistent especially
when i know what's good for you
literally the only time in recent memory
like ever actually since knowing ben he
read my book which honestly i did not
think he was gonna do like he went into
the living room like on a sunday i think
my book came out on tuesday and he
waited till the very last minute and he
sat on the couch and read the whole
thing in a matter of hours and i was
like 95 sure he was just sitting there
playing video games i was like watching
him on the dog camera but he did read it
but besides that the one time that ben
in the time that i've known him which is
almost 10 years now
the one time he came close to reading a
book was when we were on vacation and we
were both in hudson news and i didn't
read back then either but i'm like let's
get like cute books like for the trip
i bought
um i want to say it was drew barrymore's
memoir like it was in the airport it was
like the closest thing to something that
i would read
um
and ben bought aziz ansari's
memoir like didn't read a page but like
if you ask him what the last book he
read was he will say aziz i'm sorry and
like what his favorite book is aziz i'm
sorry literally that's really funny okay
i would love that because he hates when
i read like every time he comes into the
room and like i'm not watching tv and
i'm just reading he's like oh my god
you're reading again like he just
complains about it he doesn't want to
see you thrive honestly he doesn't want
to see me further my education he
doesn't want to see you advance yourself
scholastically he doesn't support women
in literature
who's married to a new york times
bestselling author that's disgusting
it's disgraceful he doesn't support um
literate women he just doesn't he
supports illiterate women
and that's disgusting
damn not right extra extra read all
about it ben stopper does not support
literacy in women and honestly i expect
a full rebuttal from him on his podcast
good guys from toast news network now
available anywhere stream podcasts um
i did finish a book last night that like
you know when you go off of goodreads
like you troll goodreads it's so hit or
miss like i found every summer after
before it became trendy i read it before
everyone else on goodreads and i was
grateful to the goodreads algorithm for
bringing me to this book the goodreads
algorithm kept shoving this one book in
my face and i was like you know what
maybe like i should just lean in what
book
the spanish love deception
when i tell you i was embarrassed to be
reading this this book like it was not
good um
and i liked the characters that was the
thing like i liked both the main
characters like the girl she had spunk
you know i liked her she was like this
fiery latina like i really liked her the
guy was of course like stoic you know
former football player like really like
my favorite but like everything else
just looks stunk
and i just know it's like it's coming
it's being pushed like
goodreads has an agenda and they're
pushing it on you and the spanish love
deception is a part of that agenda and i
just want to i want to warn everyone
like don't get tricked like it's not
good yeah goodreads is an amazing
platform i would say you know 99 of the
time like it is everything it needs to
be but sometimes it's just very
like a biased and almost like they have
an agenda
right like they personally wrote the
book themselves and they want as many
people to read it as possible or they're
getting money you know per or they work
with certain publishers or whatever but
or it's just like those are the books
that surface because that's what
everyone's reading because that's what
like the book world has put forward you
know what i mean maybe goodreads is just
like a victim
of publishing
politics 100
and so are we we're merely victims
merely victims i am reading my book so
slowly because i just haven't had the
time i was at like 15 yesterday and i
started it like six days ago
but it just got crazy like now i'm only
at 20 now and like oh my god it's insane
it's called before we were yours by lisa
wingate and apparently it's based on
true things that happen this isn't a
true story but the crazy thing that
happened and this seems like is
happening
is something that did happen and i'm
just like in the world or to the author
in the world got it and i'm not okay
it's really it's sickening like it's
it's a book where it's like a physical
reaction yeah to what's going on so i
really want to
get through it because then we are
recording the redheads next week so i
have to get through it we're reading
everything i know about love by dolly
alderton it is a snitch's choice for
everyone who loves to jump in on a
snitch's choice come in the waters warm
but snitch kind of shook things up this
month which i love for her since we've
read literally the same book three books
in a row from her because this is a
memoir and it's apparently very
self-reflective about like your 20s what
you learn along the way i think
what from what i've read from the
redheads who have already read it
they relate to different pieces of it
some people relate to the whole thing
some people relate to less or more so
i'm really excited to have a
conversation about like what the [ __ ]
we're up to in our 20s stitches growing
up
snitch is growing up that's the headline
snitch is growing up and ben doesn't
support illiterate women
that's today's title
should it be ben doesn't support
literate women or ben supports
illiterate women
but illiterate women deserve support so
right that's true and it sounds
condescending like there's
literally it's not that like
there's nothing bad about being
illiterate like it's no
honestly if you're saying he supports
them it kind of sounds like it makes it
sheds him in a positive light and he's
trying to help them become literate
which is not what he's doing no no he's
not reading to them no
ben doesn't support literate women
she's not a christian
she could be a jew and believe in god
ain't that the truth says oh my god i
saw
the most insane you know when like
you've seen enough internet
yeah like the internet has out
internetted itself
there was like this thread on twitter
and like people were being dead
[ __ ] serious
talking about anne frank
having
white privilege
and i was so
shook up
by this conversation
i
i really couldn't that's what i had to
start reading that's why i finished my
book because i said you know what
interest not today today thank you so
much a conversation between serious
people
or so how did you find it
because it okay so it went so viral
because somebody had tweeted it like you
know i'm gonna figure out the right way
to phrase this but um
i don't really know if there is
and frank had white privilege and i was
like
and she's really she was so privileged
right the replies were so like mixed but
the tweet had like thousands of retweets
and favorites like there's no way people
don't think this is crazy right
yeah
and that's when i really like
i had had enough
yeah i've seen what i've needed to see
good day
but what's crazy is like there probably
are a lot of people aside from in the
mixed reviews who like would be like
yeah
she did yeah or at least like entertain
the conversation and you know what
personally i'm not getting like i'm not
even gonna explain to you why that's so
[ __ ] stupid
beyond beyond
so that's what i did last night i read a
book after seeing enough
that you're seeing enough yeah i had a
productive evening as well little
you know emails emails emails if you got
an email for me at 11 p.m what's up i'm
so glad you brought that up speaking of
emails you were 100 right that jlo was
doing not a vogue exclusive but on the
jlo.com exclusive she released the sneak
peek pics of her wedding on her
newsletter and she posted on her
instagram at like
literally noon like sneak peek on the
jlo.com
and i had signed up yesterday you all
saw me sign up no two days ago
you all saw me sign up that email did
not come in for several several hours i
got it around 7pm
do you think that they crashed the on
the jlo server
no
what i do think though is
somebody who works in like email
marketing had messaged me like if they
have your email on file as being
previously unsubscribed like you get
pushed to the back
why is it like a cue for emails i didn't
realize when there's this newsletter
some people get it sooner than other
people it's technology i have no idea
but i do think her releasing the photos
on thejlo.com was the best thing that
ever happened to chris appleton because
he posted a lot of his photos on
instagram and tick tock and like
why subscribe when you could just see it
on chris appleton
yeah well we have a story about jlo and
her wedding luke's today so save all
your thoughts yeah because there's also
there's things going on with leah
uh oh
our
resident expert leah remini stan will
dive in after the break
after the
break don't go anywhere we'll be right
back
you know i do love being like an uh a
personality in new media like a digital
girly but part of me like was meant to
be like
hi i'm claudia ashrei and this is your
eyewitness news movie minute no offense
that was like a little um
like lackluster stale yeah okay hold on
try again i don't know why i was like
taking it too seriously you're like
depressed maybe because you're like
working for the news yeah like some low
low-level
local she's a weather woman in alaska
hi i'm claudia ashrei and this is your
eyewitness news movie minute that was
definitely more effervescent but just
for me like i just knew it was you know
a front because we just saw your last
date okay let me do one more time okay
after the break man chained to a well
for 65 years emerges and he's a jew
don't go anywhere
we'll have the answers when we come back
oh that was good well you like in
another world like should have been you
know
an actual tv
anchor host
when you were in college you hosted the
colgate centennial or whatever that
thing was called was it a radio channel
it was like a little web show
icarly
little web show yeah uh yeah no i guess
that was that was like my dream job but
this is so much better
this is so much better than that
literally and like i don't think anyone
will hire me
right now with your disgraced background
gurley good luck
you better we both better pray to the
lord that this show stays successful for
as long as possible because the odds of
us
getting another job after yesterday on
the show i said build the wall like no
uh but the good news is the uh the way
this show stays successful or not is
completely dependent on us so yeah and
by the way like if you missed
yesterday's episode like i didn't say it
in a serious like it was a joke okay
like please am i about to cancel myself
again it was a really funny segment you
should check it out 100
100 percent
okay i think without further ado
it is time to i guess when i do this
part this is like me on my anchor woman
grind
yes without further ado they don't talk
like that though but okay
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and we'll have more for you after a word
from our sponsors
oh
yes
and now a word from our sponsors today's
episode is brought to you by bruce an
electric toothbrush that will change the
way you think about brushing your teeth
with powerful sonic technology and ultra
gentle bristles the brush redefines what
it means to have super clean teeth it's
that feeling when you just leave the
dentist a fresh whole clean mouth but
every single day i use my brush this
morning i'm going on like a year and a
half with bruce and i've seen results i
love the aesthetically pleasing design
on my countertop ben loves it it's
travel friendly the battery lasts so
long and you don't want to miss out when
they drop new colors because it's kind
of like chanel
they use industry leading sonic
technology to produce 42 000 brush
strokes per minute and that is 300 times
300 brush strokes per minute so this
helps with deep cleaning in the hard to
reach places you can get your tongue
they have different settings for
different parts of your mouth it comes
the kit comes with three uh brush heads
and their charging stand which is
magnetic you can get 20 off when you
pick up your brush brush kit and the
plan when you go to brush dot com slash
toast that's 20 off your bruce brush kit
and the plan when you go to bruce
b-r-u-u-s-h dot com slash toast today's
episode is also brought to you by seed
it turns out everything you think you
know about probiotics may be wrong like
that probiotic tortilla chip you bought
at the grocery store too good to be true
well the ds01tm
daily symbiotic is real is the real deal
and it's from seed because not all
probiotics are created equally so the
broad spectrum two in one probiotic and
prebiotic 24 strain broad spectrum
probiotic and prebiotic are formulated
for digestive gut immune and additional
system systemic benefits so if you've
been wanting to get into a prebiotic or
probiotic and you don't really know
where to start because it can be kind of
overwhelming and there's so many out
there seed is a brand that you can trust
it
obviously is beneficial for your gut but
so much more beyond that it helps with
the ease of bloating healthy regularity
ease of evacuation if you know what i
mean duty central it'll support your gut
barrier your skin health your heart
health and the micronutrient synthesis
so this is like a really easy way to get
into just like bettering yourself
overall um it's not overwhelming to
start seed is a great brand
and you can start a new healthy habit
today when you go to seed.com toast and
use the code toast if you want 20 off
your first month of seeds ds01tm daily
symbiotic that's seed.com toast and use
code toast for 20 off i recently became
a probiotic girly and i know people have
been telling me to do it for a long time
and it wasn't until i found seed that i
actually started doing it and you will
notice like a visible difference in your
um digestive tract i think that's a good
way to put it your dutylicious moments
and there's nothing better than just
being like a dutylicious girly that's
really what i wanted to say a regular
dutylicious girl yeah so my body's too
delicious for you babe i don't think
you're ready for this duty i don't think
you're ready for it i'm not
but i am now thanks to seed
are you ready for our first story
yes jennifer lopez has shared the three
ralph lauren wedding dresses that she
wore for her nuptials with ben affleck
in an epic all-white wedding ceremony at
his georgia home on august 20th she
sported three ralph lauren gowns in one
night the first which she wore to walk
down the aisle was a twist on the
designer's classic turtleneck column
dress with over a thousand handkerchiefs
and 50 meters of fabric they were cut
into ruffles and attached by hand the
bride also wore nearly a hundred
thousand dollars worth of mickey moto
jewelry pairing delicate white pearl and
diamond earrings with a matching floral
ring
she also shared two more wedding dress
looks each one more
stunning stunning and i would say
extravagant than the next because
usually you start with the big one and
then you get more comfortable and then
comfortably get
jumpsuit
exactly not for j.lo though she went for
all the way off
so um i find it so interesting like
because jlo and ben thus far have been
just like extreme thirst monsters about
their whole relationship and i feel like
there wasn't really any hoopla around
these pictures and that's because she
did on the jlo.com like it kind of
muffled the excitement i think as if it
had been like a people exclusive a vogue
exclusive martha stewart weddings
exclusive the not exclusive like it just
wasn't as big of a deal um and i guess
like she sacrificed that pr moment to
gather data for her tech company
which is totally fun
um
i just feel like
like nobody cares
yeah i agree i really hope that these
emails are worth it like email marketing
is big business and if you have a huge
list of email subscribers like you can
sell that for a ton of money
so
i'm the business woman in me is like
great but also the business woman to me
is like jlo has like so many business
ventures like did you really need these
emails yeah like honestly we're not
living in the dot-com boom anymore like
i don't think
her like you could sell data for a good
amount of money but like not as much as
you used to be able to i think it's
still big business data is the most
valued um commodity in the world more
than oil yes more than oil
but like she's when i signed up like you
just need your email like some people do
first name last name birthday gender
like give me your email and i'll give
you the word targeted
that's literally should be a slogan for
on the jlo on thejlo.com give us your
email we'll give you the world give us
your email and you won't stop hearing
from
email marketing companies for the rest
of your life and you'll have to start a
new email and take that email off your
phone because you're getting more spam
than actual productivity wait jayla's
giving gen shaw energy
no i mean this is all legal and i don't
think she sold her dad no i'm just
kidding it's totally legal it's just
annoying
and it's just weird and kind of low brow
for someone of jlo's status and i just
don't understand how it's such big
business when it's like when i get an
email from someplace that i did not
subscribe to even when i get it to like
something i did subscribe to because i
shopped online
straight to deletion don't even open it
like how does that make you guys money
to the person who invented like the
unsubscribe button on apple
kiss me on the mouth
yeah that and the one where if you get a
verification passcode it comes up as
like uh we're living in the connection
to that person
kiss me on my butthole literally like i
love this man
yeah or a woman or a woman
i would love to the person who invented
the code thing where it pops up you
don't have to leave the screen
literally fellatio for all we need more
capability such as that one yeah like
actually making our lives better not
just making us buy new chargers every
month
i have so many chargers because all of
my devices now require different charge
my new ipod has a lightning cable my two
computers have two different chargers
riddle me that one
no like being a tech girly means having
if you could see this i know you haven't
been here
in a month if you could see the studio
like there's curds
everywhere
same over here
there shouldn't be chords everywhere i
cleaned up the studio before i left it
looks nice right every time you we you
go back and forth
your turn is set i have to reset exactly
that's tough and so i can't even tape
down curds because then you come back
yeah no
kurds will be like aren't we supposed to
be like in a technological like
technology advanced society i thought
we're curd cutting aren't we curd free
like
yes but then okay so you want a curd cut
you could have some like wireless
charger that one you need to charge
and two craps out
very quickly no i i know i know
so
the moral of the story is j.lo looked
gorgeous at her wedding she did she
looked very beautiful um
and those were just kind of no they just
like this whole thing gives nothing
yeah but you know what maybe she just
like wants to be not she's not low-key
she's never going to be but she's like
instead of being like so extra with ben
like let me make some money
yeah
and i'll accomplish the same thing
everyone's going to be obsessed with my
writing regardless and like then i don't
have to like thirst out people vogue
whatever it is speaking of vogue
weddings though since they didn't get
jlos
they got sarah hyland and wells adams
wedding photos which were quite gorgeous
and questions have been answered as to
was bachelor nation schmoozing with
sofia vergara and the answer is big fat
yes
yeah and you know what actually made me
have like a lot of respect for wells
because not only did he still invite
like his bachelor friends who are like
low brow compared to sofia vargara and
the cast of modern family yeah um
but he doubled down literally everyone
was there there was the 25 bachelor
contestants yeah he didn't make i
thought that was really cool like very
um
like stand up stand up
guy of him you know it's easy to drop
your loser friends when you're married
to literally an actress from the biggest
show of all time you know yeah i agree
and chris harrison was there and
crystals were there the chris's were out
and about nick vile jason tardik caitlyn
bristow everyone
ben higgins
yeah which was really nice you know i
don't give a lot of real estate in my
mind to wells and sarah highland i know
so many people are obsessed with them i
and i like
when they got together i thought it was
the coolest thing and then you know
their ship is at sea and i've moved on
but so it hadn't really sunk into me
like what
the fact that they're together that
they're now married and he's from the
bachelor and she at one point like was
on the highest
show
on television
and they're married from like just at
dms
and it's just so beautiful
to see no it really is and now like it's
we we're completely immune to it because
it's become so normalized but like lest
we not forget the time when there was
like speculation they're like there's no
way and then they were and it was just
like a crazy time to be
alive yeah and it couldn't have happened
to like a really like a bigger mensch in
bachelor nation like everybody
exclusively has nice things to say about
him he wasn't this like dick who was
like the hottest guy on the show he was
just like this really handsome
nice salt of the earth guy and that came
through and sarah liked what she saw
nice guys don't finish last moral of the
story they really don't they look
beautiful and they got married and sent
to inez which will always be the
engagement of raquel
and james and james from vanderpump
roles also speaking which leads to our
next story which leads beautifully into
our next story i couldn't have planned
it any better
sheena shay and brock davies are married
inside the vanderpump rules is couple's
mexico wedding so jlo sent her exclusive
to on the jlo sarah hyland sent hers to
vogue and sheena sent hers to people and
i'm loving all this exclusive content no
but you know what everyone
everyone who you just mentioned
should be extremely grateful to j-lo
because if j-lo had then taken vogue it
would have knocked everyone down then it
would have been sarah and wells with
people sheena and us magazines brock an
okay magazine yeah like everyone would
have gotten knocked down a peg but no
jayla was a bride who supports other
brides and because she wanted her own
data she lifted everyone up we're moving
on up exactly so congratulations are in
order for sheena and brock the
vanderpump world stars tied the knot on
tuesday in front of their closest family
and friends at the dreams natural resort
and spa in cancun mexico people
exclusively confirms sheena said i just
wanted us to have a good time with every
person who was important to us
she said they were happy to be able to
get that time for a few days with all of
our friends and family to celebrate us
the stars were joined by a slew of their
co-stars including ariana maddox and
raquel levis who were part of sheena's
bridal party as well as tom sandoval and
tom schwartz who acted as two of brock's
groomsmen
brock said they're a big part of our
lives guest also included past cast
members like jax brittany and kristen
no stassi no katie no sassy no katie not
surprising especially like i don't even
know if well first of all sheena wasn't
at sassy's wedding and
maybe even if sassy was invited like she
has a baby so you just you don't go to
everything you can't dance at every
wedding anymore did you say lala was
there lala was there because i saw it on
lala's instagram okay she wasn't
mentioned in this article now i have a
lot to say i'm going to start with um
all the positive things because they're
mostly positive just this article gets a
little weird because like the person
didn't change the tenses in the pitch
email says sheena will be serving her
guests
they will be dining on and they can look
forward to fireworks like it's
it's giving lazy but
sheena looked so gorgeous
i was watching lala's video she her and
barack did their first dance i didn't
watch with sound i think that would have
made it better but then at one point
like sheena walks off and she brings
back summer
and the three of them danced together
and i seriously had chills like i know
that gina and brock are sheena and brock
and we can talk about that any other
time but if you suspend disbelief just
while watching this video exactly i'm
not i'm not thinking about all that we
saw last season today i'm just not i'm
thinking about the beauty and it looked
so beautiful sheena looked beautiful and
i'm so happy for her i hope this is
everything that she wants and i truly
was taken with how absolutely stunning
she looked
okay two things one were brock's
children there
they didn't make the people magazine
article if they were
and i'm gonna say sure that'll be a
story line i'm sure that they weren't
i'm sure that they weren't as well and
the second thing was i was
was i the only one who was like really
surprised that these two had a formal
wedding
like after their shenanigans last year
like wanting to literally like use the
tablecloth from
james and raquel's engagement party as
sheena's veil like i was like i was just
shocked that they would then throw their
own formal event
well i think that
i feel like sheena would probably have
always wanted a wedding she is very
traditional traditional and quite chewy
in that sense and
maybe she always planned to do that but
all the other stuff you know and we've
all been there like it doesn't have to
be the biggest and the baddest so maybe
they just wanted to like get it into the
show have it nice and maybe they also
might have learned from that and been
like let's do our own thing let's have
our own moment and sheena had like the
very typical la traditional wedding lest
we not forget mike shay
um so she probably just wanted like this
one to be like smaller and like actually
fun but it doesn't look like it was
small it looked like you know a first
wedding
oh
so i'm sure she wants like i'm that
doesn't surprise me though for sheena
like sheena's gonna give everything her
all
yeah and that's like one of her best and
worst qualities so here is where the
article you know it's a really long
article filled with so many details and
eventually the writer just starts to
copy and paste gives up
afterward attendees will take to the
roof for a cocktail hour enjoying a wide
selection of drinks and appetizers
guests will dine on a surf and turf
steak and salmon menu during the
reception with a vegan lasagna also
available as an option
the newlywed pears the newlyweds first
seriously who cares what the vegan
option at someone's wedding is why is
that an important detail i don't know
the newlyweds first dance will be
soundtracked by leon bridges is beyond
because sheena says the song's lyrics
are very close to their hearts wait
here's an interesting factoid while they
originally wanted their vanner pump
rules co-stars band tom sandoval and the
most extras to perform complicated
logistics led them to choose a dj
instead for a reception entertainment
attendees will also be treated to a fire
to works display from pyrocaribe
the fun doesn't stop there as the night
continues with an after party at an
on-site sea note
sheena will change into a short dress
from casablanca bridal in newport beach
california it gets close out the night
with tacos and more dancing with the
help of okay jackie seriously like let's
not be negative so let's just stop
reading okay
i'm just i'm being negative about the
tenses of this article you didn't need
to include all of that and if you did
just don't pretend like it's straight
from sheena's email
yeah and i really don't um want to be
mean
so i'll just be quiet any thoughts on
tom sandoval on the most extras
like i said
i really don't want to be mean so i'll
just be quiet
and according to people magazine dj
james kennedy was doing the after party
i have
been at many event that james kennedy
has dj'd and he's the real [ __ ] deal
man no he doesn't play zone music he
plays like that one bad man she's but
but
he's actually a pretty good dj like he
gets lit like you know the way he
presses play on that is so
unique
never been done before no he's actually
pretty good like that he's a good dj for
a wedding after party
with all your friends and your friends
dj it's hard to find a dj for the after
party who knows a dj
no i know
i know a playlist that's hard flames
it's a very mellow chill playlist
because we're just chill girls we're not
like other girls
we're shy
are you ready for our next story
only if it's next story that's brought
to you by bowling branch
yes
bowling branch sheets aren't just
buttery breathable and impossibly
comfortable they get softer with every
wash
bowl and branch so we are bowling branch
girlies i live in a bowling branch home
jackie lives in a bowling branch home we
have the signature hemmed collection so
the signature hemp sheets from bowling
branch are their best seller they use
the highest quality threads on earth for
superior softness and a better night's
sleep they're so luxurious they've been
beloved by three u.s presidents why i
really like them is because i'm a very
um you know temperature conscious
sleeper and i find that a lot of sheets
make me so warm they're not really
breathable and why i love bowling
branches because you really can feel a
difference like in when you wake up
you're not in a pool of your own sweat
it helps control your temperature
they're super soft they wash really well
there's tons of reviews online tons of
five star reviews that um
are hella accurate and a lot of my
bedroom accessory my bedroom tings are
from bowlin branch as well like my
waffle blanket jackie has a two in like
a nude i have it in blue um i always get
questions about it so it really is like
premium looking like very aesthetically
pleasing but also
made of good quality threads
they also give you a 30 night risk free
trial with free shipping and returns on
all orders so there's really no reason
not to try bowling branch like what if
you just tried bowling branch what if
you just get 15 off your first set of
sheets when you use promo code toast at
bowlingbranch.com
that's bowlin branch b-o-l-l-a-n-d
branch dot com promo code toast
thank you so much claudium
next up nicole kidman has lit the
internet ablaze with her new tone
muscles in her cover shoot for the
magazine called perfect have you seen
these pics
a fake magazine called perfect it's a uk
magazine no one's talking about the
magazine we're talking about
the pictures oh my god by the way um
celebrities are always on the cover of
fake magazines like
grazia you know like
yeah
uh wonderland yep
um and i always wonder like how these
random magazines like get celebrities to
get be on the cover like it's always i
think it's a combination of things one i
think when you're really into that world
you know wonderland is his major
uh but also like if a photographer a
certain photographer like wants to work
with you if you have a thing to promote
if there's like a fashion thing element
like these pictures
grazia from at least my point of view
like started out as a fake magazine and
now i think it's like pretty legit
yeah it's giving lydia from real
housewives of orange county nobleman
yeah i mean nobleman has a lot of noble
men on the cover they actually had
someone um
pretty famous on the cover at one point
do you remember who i'm talking about
yes but i feel like it was like matt
damon or something it was like someone's
legit and i was like lydia
go off well no nicole kidman is on the
cover looking buff as hell and everyone
is shook up she's showing off some
seriously toned biceps ads and quads in
the photo while wearing a colorful
diesel tank top and modified gray belt
turn skirt with a very mod haircut that
i do not believe is her actual hair
short in the front long in the back and
is she looking like this for a
particular role or that's just what she
looks like on a day-to-day basis it's
giving that's what she looks like on a
day-to-day basis i mean i don't know
what she has coming up next but she is
shredded
and and nicole kidman is like so many
things like and she's one of those
gorgeous gorgeous women ever and i just
never would have predicted that like she
under that [ __ ] swole bro yeah no
she'll beat you up she's swole as hell
i mean you have to think like she had to
be in good shape to get away from that
scary ass [ __ ] tom cruise like
and scientology as a whole you can't
just run away if you're not in good
shape you know it's true
um so i always knew she was mentally
very strong you know speaking of
scientology you never told us your leah
remini t
no t but like there are reports from
like totally
unsubstantiated and like un
what's the word i'm looking for reliable
sources that like there is you know a
break in the friendship and that you
know her relationship with ben affleck
was the like catalyst for them
you know
taking time apart
leah and j lo
whoa
but it's totally like it's like it's
like hollywood unlocked like it's not
it's
until it's not just like
pete breaking up just like he could be
being together and kim and pete breaking
up yeah
um
but nicole kidman
i
love this woman
i you know
there are many people in hollywood like
if i if i had to even if i liked them a
lot like i could say negative things
about you know even people i love like
if i had to come up with something mean
to say like i could
i literally have scoured every corner of
my mind looking for something negative
to say about nicole kidman and i truly
can't yeah queen queen on her queen [ __ ]
oh also i don't know if you saw this
report um about andrew garfield
no i saw his name but he's something
about a role yeah so he went on a crazy
diet for six months you know to get in
shape and i'm curious where lily
reinhardt is yeah she's been really
quiet
yeah
where are all the people who were like
coming at him for
wanting to get into shape for the mech
ella andrew garfield did it where's
andrew just setting a bad example
such a terrible example also lilly ryan
has a new movie on netflix that looks
really good yes a lot of people are
talking about it it's giving gwyneth
paltrow sliding doors like you know if
you made this train your life would have
been this way but if you missed the
train your life would have ended out
completely differently you know very
butterfly effect yeah um
similar but not similar and it looks
pretty good people are talking about it
it does look good i hope to watch it
someday
you know if i find the time it's
something that i would have watched in a
heartbeat like a year ago netflix is
getting their claws into the riverdale
cast um i'm sure they saw how well
riverdale performed on netflix after the
show
would rap on cw
they have a new i think it's a show or a
movie with um camila mendes that looks
also really good giving high school
realness
and i love that for them like good good
call yeah agreed they should also really
pick up dynasty
cast
or the show they do
no like pick it up officially oh and
create more seasons yeah
yeah it has a huge international
following on netflix i think actually
dynasty made more money for netflix than
the cw made yeah
so it would kind of behoove them
to do what they did with like gilmore
girls you know yeah i would love that or
arrested development
right are you ready for our next story
just some positive relationship news um
so refreshing we haven't spoken about
them in a while in a while but i just
want everyone to know that channing
tatum and joey kravitz have celebrated
their one year anniversary they have now
hit the one-year mark and that's why
sources are saying it's serious i mean
at one year it's just like ramona singer
says like you need to know someone
through every season
and then it's serious
so they have celebrated winter spring
summer and fall together how old is
channing and how old is zoe kravitz
channing is 42 zoe kravitz is 33.
okay that's a nice age and does zombie
kravitz have kids no no
uh
no i don't think so
because i wonder if that's like a next
step for them like he has a family with
jen and dewan like that part of his life
is like almost behind him but she's 10
years younger and like that could be
something she wants he only has he has
one daughter
so oh okay could go either way
yeah i also feel like what he very
briefly dated um jessie
james
jesse j jessie j sorry oh my god there's
so many jessie's you know jesse james
jesse james stacker jessie j jesse
gardner
[Laughter]
um
i feel like when he
was briefly dating her was the time when
she was like talking a lot about her
fertility and like her struggles with
getting pregnant almost as if like they
were working on it together you know oh
yeah
so i think he does want more kids like i
think this relationship has potential
like to have legs
totally well a source is telling people
that they are very happy their careers
are a big
focus and they share this passion when
they're off they're very low key they
enjoy quiet date nights with friends but
most often just hang out at home
channing is serious about zoey it's not
a casual relationship they have been
exclusive for a long time
i mean i hear that
i hear that i totally forgotten about
them which is always a good sign of a
public relationship
yeah
like just like you're blissfully happy
to be annoying i want everyone to have
that bit of good news today like know
that our ships are out to see we only
report whether they're when they're
sinking or they're like fledgling new
baby ships but not about like these rock
solid couples that you would have never
put these two together but they're
making it work
i couldn't have said it better myself
truly great so now are you ready for our
fifth and final story
i am yes yes i am it's a little true
crime toast
yeah because it has a social media
component which is where we come in
so i i don't know if you've been
following this story but a missing
california team name keely rodney has
been missing for a few weeks and um law
enforcement has been looking for her but
a bunch of youtube divers did in 35
minutes what cops couldn't do in two
weeks in the search for her and they
found her car and her body in a lake
the deep oh i saw this on tick tock the
deep diving youtubers who claim to have
found missing california teen keeley
rodney said monday it took them just 35
minutes even though authorities had
spent nearly 20 000 man hours failing to
find her adventures with purpose started
searching prosser creek reserve
reservoir early sunday and almost
immediately found what they believe is
16 year olds 2013 crv with the body
inside they said monday it has now been
confirmed that that is term
they said we began our search for keeley
at 10 40 am lead investigator doug
bishop said in an update on monday by 11
15 a.m one of the volunteers detected an
object underwater using cutting edge
sonar technology they knew it was a car
in roughly 14 feet of water and only 55
feet offshore with divers soon
confirming it was indeed kylie's vehicle
we immediately notified family in law
enforcement and her dad and grandpa were
on the scene within minutes
also
they have solved
23 other cold cases this team of divers
and
youtubers
wow okay so i actually had seen this on
tick tock um there was like news footage
going around because the reservoir where
they found her lake like had already
been cleared by police like
they were like yeah we looked it's not
there oh
which is a huge stain on the police
department like come on seriously yeah
um like a bunch of amateurs can find it
and you already looked there well
they're not amateurs but they right
there's no reason here these there's no
reason why they should have access to
better technology better resources and
manpower than law enforcement themselves
that's true
um and i think that's an important point
is that these people are not amateurs
because i think people you know listen
to one true crime podcast and start like
sniffing around
national parks for clues
and
i think a lot of the times people who
have their like good intentions just get
in the way yes and make more of an issue
for police but it's nice that you know
there's a happy ending here
yeah not a happy ending obviously like a
terror it's terrible story that a young
girl is dead yes but to have a
conclusion and to have answers
do we have any answers as to like
was this nefarious like did she
was it an accident would someone put her
at the bottom of the reservoir i
personally i don't know and i think it's
too soon to tell but hopefully we'll
have answers soon but the founder of
adventures with purpose said that he
started the group in july 2018 using his
diving skills to clean up underwater
habitats riddled with garbage but then a
family reached out to them in 2019
asking if they might be able to use
their skills to help find a missing
loved one and he put their skills to
good use since then they have helped
families find closure through their
search missions including this
particular one
twenty
three cold cases solved see stuff like
this happens a lot like on tick tock
sometimes like i'll get there's a lot of
people who go magnet fishing which is
like you throw
this very very high-powered magnet into
like a lake a stream any sort of body of
water um and it can attract anything
metal
from like
20 feet away it's like very very
powerful um and sometimes they find you
know weapons that were used in like cold
cases so things like that happen they
can find a car
um so while i don't think it's like good
for people like anyone to encourage you
know regular people to put themselves in
danger and like get in the way of police
work sometimes it does like even with um
gabby potito you know there was footage
from like another you know group of
people who were camping or vanning
through national parks and they had
footage like that actually helped the
investigation so sometimes it's good but
sometimes it's not
yeah i think in this particular case i
don't think the message should be like
more people should get out there and try
deep diving but i think that perhaps
this team could be training law
enforcement around the country things
like that no like they need a government
contract
yeah
they're doing good work and that's i
you'd love to see internet people making
a difference you love to see internet
people making a difference and i'm just
really um
terrible story about this girl i'm
wishing her family you know peace in the
upcoming weeks it's gonna be tough
yeah wow
unexpected true crime moment i know but
i know how everyone responded to the
true crime moment that you shared last
week plus with the social media
component i actually i found that to be
a very
riveting headline i also found the
conversation that we had about true
crime podcast last week to be really
interesting because we got a lot of good
feedback that a lot of like the really
big um true crime podcast like what's
the big one
uh crime junkies morbid true crime
junkies drunkies crime junkies um that
they work with you know the families to
raise money they work with all these
great organizations which um was great
but then it got me thinking um and this
is something i feel like
shannon ford brought up to me once
because we're obsessed with like
watching the podcast charts
morbid is the name of like a really
popular true crime podcast right yeah
and they're in comedy yeah
how what's funny about crime
i don't know i've never listened to it
so maybe it is funny but like seems like
a weird choice
yeah you have you would have to listen
to it to make that
right and that's not just me saying that
because they're always ahead of us but
on its face yeah what's funny i don't
know yeah it seems like a very kind of
insensitive category but again i don't
know
maybe we should listen
i'd rather listen to the morning toast
or good guys or mood with lauren
elizabeth or the snatchler or caviar
dreams with margaret josephs or girls
night with alexis watters or the
redheads book club because i heard it's
never too late to become a redhead or
probably a podcast with shannon ford
it's never too late to become a redhead
thank you for resurfacing that i just
want to circle back to something from
the beginning of the show we're
recording our episode next week today
would be the perfect time to decide to
become a redhead and finish the book in
time for next thursday's episode this is
your sign this is your sign if you've
been looking for one maybe feeling like
oh no everyone who's a redhead like they
have too many inside jokes i'll never
get it if i listen to the episode i
won't know about the girls or who's who
it's not like that it's never like you
know what you should do
an intrigue like an introductory intro
to redheads um
that you can kind of just leave in the
app store
bios on everyone how you all know each
other whose book type is what
yeah that's a good idea that is a good
idea you're well you're welcome i'll
talk to the girls try and get another
it's hard enough finding one time it
only needs to be like 20 minutes it
doesn't need to be like a whole long ass
episode i know but we like to we really
like put a lot of quality into
everything that we do like nothing at
the redheads is below that standard
and by the way i think on a lot of
podcast platforms you can have like an
intro episode stay at the top
yeah so that every time someone comes to
the red heads it comes up right first
and then into the episodes which i think
is cool okay we'll work on that yeah
just letting you know
um so the show's not done yet because
it's wednesday which means it's dear
toasters day
and we're gonna help some of our fellow
toasters navigate through some of life's
trials and tribulations and that is
brought to you by fashion pass so many
toasters already know and love fashion
pass but it is truly the stiniest
clothing rental service you will get
unlimited rentals for one flat price and
you have a bunch of different options
when it comes to clothing rentals but
unfortunately all of those other options
are for fugly clothes like fashion pass
is that [ __ ] because the price it makes
sense but the clothes are actually cute
there's stuff that's actually being sold
right now on websites like revolve it's
brands that are sickening like it's
brands you want not just like random
grandma moomoos
not that there's anything wrong with the
moomoo um
period
you'll save so much money because you're
not out buying clothes and they have the
best brands for love and lemons free
people show me your mumu amanda up
richard
if you're there they have a bunch of
different plans but we're on the
trendsetter plan so you pick three
clothing items and two accessories for
every order and you can switch them out
as many times per month as you want they
ship super fast they take care of dry
cleaning so you just send it back with
the pre-labeled bag they give you and
when you're done you'll get to choose
new items if you've been wanting to get
into clothing rental or you've been
doing clothing rental but haven't really
feel like the clothes are like cute and
fun and young and trendy and on trend
check out fashion pass i know you guys
love it and you're always asking for the
code if you go to fashionpass.com and
use code toast you'll get 40 off your
first month so you can try it for just
39
it's unlimited rentals for just 39 with
code toast
at fashionpass.com
oh raw eh ready
if you ever want to write into your
toasters get some advice from your
favorite girlies totally anonymously
it's dear toasters gmail.com
dear jackson claude my husband and i we
should also change the name of the
segment from deer testers to dear
jackson claude agreed but we'll leave it
you know
perfection for now rebrands are coming
like once one day soon there will be
rebrands a plenty around here my husband
and i recently moved from the city to
the suburbs about a year ago my husband
has two good friends that still live in
the city so occasionally if they all
hang out
at our house they end up staying super
late drinking coming back to our house
making late night food and then just
sleeping over
when they sleep at our house they're set
up in the living room on a pull-out
couch we have a small house and no guest
room we have a baby and a dog so in the
morning i have to go into the kitchen
which is connected to the living room to
make a bottle make coffee feed our dog
let him out etc
i feel like i have to be quiet and not
wake anyone up mind you it's like 6 or 7
a.m when the baby wakes up but sometimes
they'll sleep till like 11 or so i feel
trapped upstairs when they wake up
until they wake up and leave they're
respectful they clean up after
themselves and they always thank us for
our hospitality i understand the
occasional staying the night if they've
had too much to drink but sometimes it
is
it isn't planned is it just me or is it
weird that 30 year olds still have
sleepovers i wanted to get your thoughts
thank you
that's a little
not
not the vibe you know especially weird
like with it's not necessarily weird
you know it's nice that he's still close
with his city friends and that they feel
comfortable enough and that like you
know them you guys being in the suburbs
isn't going to stop them from doing what
they want all night and if that means
they're going to be safe and then like
crash at your place it's really nice
that they still have that relationship
but there's a time and a place in a
season for everything and having guys
crash on your couch while you have a
newborn baby like it's just not the time
or the place so i would just say
something to your husband and just try
and figure out like a better
solve and i don't think you would be
having this problem if they weren't
sleeping in the living room right yeah
yeah so i would get creative with like
futons in whatever other room you have
whether it's an office like something
like a den i don't know what the house
looks like um and if this is truly your
only option then that's it but try and
think creatively because it is really
annoying like it halts your whole
[ __ ] day when you can't even make a
pizza living in the main living spaces
how often is this happening that it
actually is like bothering an issue
because if it was like a once you know a
blue moon thing you wouldn't be writing
in like is this happening
every few weeks if so like they need to
set a time for the night to be over and
have their uber take them back to the
city like you're not being even if it's
3 a.m like they need to know that that's
when they're or a hotel
airbnb
like i don't want to discourage your
husband from like hanging on to
friendships just because you guys moved
like you shouldn't really change
anything but you're also in this
transitional period in your life and
like when you have a baby like you have
to be selfish and that means your
husband's 30 year old friends can't
sleep on the couch honestly like grow up
yeah especially if it's becoming this
regular yeah if it's like once every six
months okay but if it's like once a
month like that's [ __ ] annoying yeah
and and also like at some point have the
internet grown have these are two grown
to be having
sleepovers i'm sorry i said it and
mostly especially your husband
he's married he has a baby like what's
he doing once a month up until three a.m
sleeping on the couch like nah yeah
there's a time and a place and a season
and this is not the season for that
so you mama like you have to channel
your mama energy and do what's best for
you and your family and your baby hang
your dog
right
literally the dog has to [ __ ] so bad
can't get anywhere because [ __ ] slobs
living in the living room it's like and
maybe he's a little poop shy and he's
like all right oh there's guys on my
couch and he's just expected to take a
dump in front of these two random people
no that's no he doesn't roll like that
think of your dog
hey jackson claude we are two ogs riding
in we've been fan since the breath and
we cannot wait to see you in charlotte
tickets available at growthojob.com
charlotte
we're in a pickle and we need your help
our best friend margot has been dating a
pejom named bryce for about five years
they're getting engaged any day now and
margot has never been happier there's
just one problem
we are 99.9
sure that bryce is gay when they first
started dating we definitely noticed he
was a bit on the feminine side super
trendy and stylish pretty flamboyant but
we didn't think much of it over the last
couple of years some things have come to
light from bryce's friends his friend
group consists of girls and openly gay
men and we've met a majority of them
bryce's friends have shared with us that
right before margo and bryce started
dating bryce had taken a secret trip to
paris with his openly gay best friend
theo
bryce and theo then moved in together
and soon after that bryce and margo
started dating we also ran into bryce a
few weeks ago while he was at brunch
with his friends which was 12 girls plus
him and the way they were interacting
was as if he was the gay best friend we
have an openly gay best friend in our
group and the brunch encounter we saw
him
was giving very much similar vibes to
how we hang out with our gay bestie we
have a lot of gay friends and every time
one of them has met bryce they've asked
if he was gay we could go on for days
about all the suspicions but trying to
keep it short our main concern is that
we look do we let margaret marry this
man and then in 10 years when they're
married with kids it will come out and
they'll get divorced meanwhile we're the
awful friends who knew bryce was gay all
along
bryce treats margo like a queen and we
would hate to ruin her happiness by
bringing this to light she's extremely
sensitive and this would absolutely
destroy her what do we do do we mind our
own business to spare her feelings are
we horrible friends for not voicing our
concerns sincerely two toasters who
probably should have addressed this
years ago
okay a lot to unpack here but first the
first thing i want to say is like
a lot of what you're saying that you're
seeing is like stuff that everyone else
is seeing including he's not hiding it
including her like his personality
flamboyancy like you know close male
friendships close female friendships
like she's privy to all of these things
that you're privy to so like you you're
not telling her that like the way that
you're not telling her new information
also i mean if this was my almost fiance
like i would want to know that he's at
brunch with 12 girls like the [ __ ] are
you doing there that's also nefarious
that's imagine like your boyfriend's at
brunch with 12 girls
i would want to know that so you that
shouldn't have to be like a big sit down
you're just like by the way i saw bryce
at brunch with 12 girls like you're cool
with that why weren't you the 13th right
that's where my mind would go
see my opinion on this has changed
recently because
i feel like i was in a similar situation
with somebody that i knew who everyone
was like when we were growing up like oh
he's gay he's always hanging out with
girls but he wasn't like he just had you
know great female friendships um and it
wasn't weird and and then people
eventually stopped you know saying it um
but then he came out so at first i would
have been like you know if he's doing
all this and he's comfortable like being
you know friends with gay guys and going
on trips with them and hanging out with
a lot of girls like somebody who's in
the closet wouldn't do that
but now i don't know because right but
okay
yes but so say he had a girlfriend for
five years
what would you tell her that she doesn't
already know and see with her own two
eyes right that's true that's true i
wasn't seeing and it's like she's the
one who's like having sex with him like
she would know
yeah more than you by the way that he's
bi and she knows and maybe they don't
need to talk about it to everyone and
put their label everywhere like you
don't know what they know
right so the only thing that it sounds
like maybe she doesn't know because you
just found this out is that the trip to
paris with theo and living together so i
would just like be like by the way i
didn't know that bryce and theo like
went to paris together like and lived
together like
how was that
yeah and just in case you didn't already
know don't act like you're telling her
just make sure that she knows by
yeah
mentioning it the most important point
was the one that you made which is like
everything that you are privy to she is
privy to as well like she's not blind
she sees what you see
um
and either they've spoken about it or
she doesn't care like she wants to get
married she wants to be in a
relationship so
i don't really think
there's anything you can do just make
sure you bring up paris with you
yeah
and you can poke and prod but and like
when you see her man at brunch with 12
girls like tell her that you saw that
yeah regardless like she might like
sexual orientation she might like start
to get annoyed with you like no but you
don't have to be a snitch just be like
the brunch with 12 girls is yeah
snitchery snitchy behavior but the paris
with theo like that's you know
just interesting factoid swap yeah
see like i'm planning a trip to paris
like can i ask bryce about his trip with
theo what'd they do love that
love
um best of luck truly
hello jackson claude and brazen straz
heller
i hope you're well because i am not long
story short we had an event at my work
where an esthetician was there
performing mini facials she doesn't have
a spa and she travels to people's houses
while she was there she mentioned that i
should book her and that she would hook
it up i texted her last week and she
said oh i would love to treat you to a
facial
i think oh so nice a free facial i say
to her i say to her oh my god a treat
that is so generous you don't have to do
that she then says it's her pleasure and
would love to do so she sends a booking
and the price says zero dollars fast
forward she gets to my house does the
facial and then goes okay so i'll do 20
off today it'll be 200
i was literally so flabbergasted and i
told her that i thought this was free
and she basically gasled me into
thinking that i was wrong i was so
shocked
i paid her on my credit card just to get
her out of my house my question is
should i charge back my card should i
tell her how grossly uncomfortable i
felt in my own home so she doesn't have
to do this again to anyone i completely
forgot this ever happened or should i
completely forget this ever happened and
block her number i know this is
partially my fault and that i should
have clarified but i was completely
misled and she just let me take it and
run i just feel like she has to know how
awful this was and she should have just
said like hey
my problem it's free sorry
i have literally lost sleep over this i
feel so dumb and not only was this 200
was his facial 200 astronomical for a
facial but i could get one for half the
price at event spa sincerely and now
poor toaster okay unless you're gonna be
running into this girly like i would
just block forget move on but like if
you're gonna be seeing her a lot maybe
it's worth
you know
fixing but
at this point she's a stranger you know
she gave me a facial one time goodbye no
but i think that this is this person's
like marketing tactic i think that this
wasn't an accident i don't think that
there was a miscommunication i think
that she wanted you to think you were
getting a free facial hoodwinked you
into getting that facial and then came
in with that like it said pricier a
dollar she said she wanted to treat to a
facial like i think like this person is
kind of
running a scheme here
maybe now report her to the better
business bureau i don't know what you do
with that information and like who you
even tell her like you leave a yelp
review or something the bbb
but i don't think that was an accident
i think that you do have to pay her for
the service because it like wasn't
you know in writing or anything that
this was going on even though it was
pumped it was it said zero dollars i
know but that's a shady business and i
don't think you should feel stupid
because she
she hoodwinked you she did that on
purpose yeah i think she did that she
feels stupid but i think it's the
important lesson is like no there's no
such thing as a free lunch like no but
sometimes there really is like
sometimes there really is and especially
this random woman give a girl a facial
who she met one time at a work event
maybe like it was to show her how good
the facial like it could be marketing
i'll give you a free facility
but no instead this is what she's doing
like tricking people and
to spending 200 with her
i well you know what i would do i would
like go search yelp her instagram
comments the better business bureau see
if anyone else has complained about this
or she just like wanted to dupe you even
though i'm sure it's a pattern make sure
that like this is something she
frequently does and then blow her up
seriously that's what the better
business bureau is for
yeah okay good idea
i do think i think that you have to
pay it because it's really like she paid
it already but she's saying should i
call my credit card company and like and
not pay it yeah yeah
that's like
i don't know because like what if it was
just like a genuine miscommunication and
then like it was taking money out of her
pocket you know
from the way she's describing it i
really don't think it was oh well you
know what i would do your research see
if anyone else has said anything similar
and if they have charge that [ __ ] back
on the credit card
yeah
you just need a little bit of certainty
a little bit of proof that you're not
the only one
i don't think you're the only one i
think you were taken advantage of
me too i think it's a pattern it's
giving netflix documentary
yeah it's giving the polka king
um so those were your toasters if you
guys ever want to write in it's dear
toasters gmail.com we will always keep
your [ __ ] anonymous and you can write in
about anything that's going on in your
life work related facial related friends
related money related wedding related
anything you got we're going to do our
best to help you out and that's our show
that's our show
thank you so much for listening to the
morning chose the millennium morning
show where we deliver the past five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcasts can be
found so it's spotify itunes stitcher
public radio i have rate of cast box all
the places so whenever you listen to
podcasts find us the morning toast leave
a five star review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are hope you guys
have an enclave hump day and we'll see
you tomorrow for thursday which is our
last show of the week there is no show
friday uh taking a summer friday finally
taking a summer friday so we love you
dear ladies
love you guys have an amazing day bye
you